pourquoi a-t-on les fourmis dans les
jambes vous êtes un sac de nœud rempli
de vaisseaux sanguins un petit comme
gros dans certaines positions vous
pouvez compresser vos veines ou vos
artères ce qui provoque un
ralentissement de la circulation
forcément votre système nerveux panique
pas question de tomber à court d'oxygène
alors il déclenche une paresthésie cette
sensation d'engourdissement pour vous
indiquer qu'il est temps de bouger mais
vos nerfs sont pas infaillibles
comprimés ils peuvent envoyer des
signaux erronés par exemple à cause de
certains antibiotiques qui viennent
interférer avec vos neurones là les
fourmillements sont anormaux et
chroniques quand c'est vraiment gênant
faut opérer maintenant si on vous
demande vous savez